the haunted mansion is a family comedy
that's begging to be picked apart with
an elaborate mythology full of strange
implications that child viewers just
gloss over
while the adults in the room can't stop
thinking about them
here are a few things that only adults
notice the setup for the haunted mansion
requires the human characters to get to
the titular house as quickly as possible
and the way the evers family ends up at
gracie manor is
as a result quite simple jim and sarah
evers are realtors
one of their flyers ends up at the manor
and the ghostly owner has his butler
call them to arrange a meeting with
sarah
whom he believes is the reincarnation of
his lost
love
mom when the evers family arrives at the
house
spurred by jim's workaholic tendencies
they find the place looking like no
one's visited in some time
over the course of the movie it's
revealed that the grounds of gracie
manor feature an elaborate necropolis
and the mansion itself is a massive
monument on the landscape
so how has it and its many ghostly
residents gone unnoticed for so long
jim makes his family go to the mansion
after sarah tells him the address
and he immediately knows it's an
affluent area
so if he knows that why don't other
people
perhaps it's part of the curse
surrounding the manor but it's hard to
imagine that urban explorers or
paranormal snoopers hadn't scoped the
place out already
as the evers family explores the titular
haunted mansion
they come across a variety of ghosts it
all begins with the butler
ramsley and then edward gracie the
ghostly owner of the manor
but then things get more complicated the
film establishes that the further away
ghosts get from the main house
the more dead they are that means the
ghosts that live in the cemetery have
blue
ethereal forms and when the ghosts in
the house leave it
they take on the same ethereal form
that's a simple enough mechanic to
understand
except that there's also a ghostly horse
that's just a skeleton
running around blasting through walls
and a group of barbershop quartet ghosts
that haunt statues
a fortune teller ghost and a crystal
ball and just flat out zombies in the
tombs beneath the property
rotting flesh and all so what's with all
the different ghost forms
the obvious real life answer is to make
the movie look cooler but
why do the above ground ghosts get to
have cool blue wispy forms while the
below ground ones are just
walking rotters who want to kill
anything that moves
gracie manor is haunted because of a
curse visited on it
years earlier in the same way that the
characters in beauty and the beast are
cursed to live as animated objects
the characters of the haunted mansion
are unable to cross over into the
afterlife
over the course of the film we learned
that this curse happened because
ramsley sabotaged his master edwards
marriage proposal to his servant
elizabeth
convinced that their union couldn't
happen ramsley killed elizabeth
and made it look like a suicide causing
edward to take his own life
and as a result everyone on the grounds
of the mansion is cursed
including the victims of ramsley's crime
why do edward and elizabeth have to
suffer because of what ramsley did
they didn't do anything wrong perhaps
edward's own deliberate suicide is what
cursed the place but if that's the case
then why does everyone else have to
stick around there are good guys and bad
guys in the haunted mansion
but the curse is a raw deal for everyone
are you telling me this guy is dead and
the only reason we were brought here is
because he wants to try to get jiggy
with my wife
pretty much the haunted mansion is a
family horror comedy with almost
no outright horror elements it's based
as the title suggests
on a popular theme park attraction that
exists at both disneyland and walt
disney world
and if you go off the plot of the movie
it's all founded on what's basically a
hate crime
okay no it's serious that's serious yes
the whole reason this mansion is haunted
in the continuity of the film is because
a butler got angry that his white master
was about to marry a mixed-raced servant
and decided to poison her to prevent the
marriage from happening
he's a racist who didn't think their
marriage would look right and he just
straight up
murdered a woman because of it in a
movie based on that ride at disneyland
where grim
grinning ghost plays you can go to the
haunted mansion at one of disney's parks
and
ignore this fact but once you've seen
the haunted mansion movie
it's hard not to think about it at least
a little bit
one of the key comedic hooks of the
haunted mansion as a movie
rests on the premise that the evers
family does not know they're heading to
a house full of ghosts
when they meet the major players in
gracie manor they at first appear as
normal if a little strange human beings
one of the first things ramsley the
butler does when they arrive is
serve them an elaborate dinner later
when we meet rita the maid
she serves the evers children a plate of
fresh cookies
it's well established throughout the
film that these ghosts are able to
handle physical objects
so it's not surprising that they were
able to do things like serve
soup and bake cookies but who went to
the grocery store for them
did they have that stuff delivered and
just pay for it with old money lying
around the mansion
did they only make the food from the
stuff they grew out on the grounds
if they did we didn't see it whatever
the case
those are some very resourceful ghosts
the haunted mansion is a film in which a
house full of people are
cursed to an eternal ghostly existence
because the butler sabotaged the owner's
marriage to his lover
but we don't learn this right away the
film takes its time unfolding the
mystery of exactly why the
place is cursed and one particular
mystery isn't solved until the very
end these walls are filled
with so many memories some of them
[Music]
painful edward gracie killed himself
when he found out his lover was dead
but we see him almost immediately when
the evers family arrives at the mansion
he's cursed to be a ghost but he can
move around and
look normal his lover elizabeth is also
hanging around the house
but she exists as what the evers kids
call a ghost ball
a wordless orb floating around until she
finally possesses the body of sarah
evers at the end of the film
to tell her side of the story elizabeth
then explains she couldn't be freed
until the truth of what happened to her
was told
but what she doesn't explain is why
elizabeth did nothing wrong
she fell in love with a rich man and
then that man's butler killed her and as
a result she's punished for
unwittingly drinking poison her glowing
prison only seems to exist to serve as a
clever last minute reveal
we can pick apart the particulars of the
curse at the heart of the haunted
mansion all we want
because in terms of who it affects how
it affects them and why
it's a rather flimsy concept despite
that though
one key role seems to apply across the
board for most of the movie
the ghosts are at the mansion because
the curse is keeping them from moving on
into the afterlife
that's explained pretty early on and
when the film reaches its climax
it seems to pay off the curse is lifted
when the spirits of elizabeth and edward
are reunited
and the ghosts all float up into heaven
as bright orbs of light
signifying their final passage from this
world except
the ghosts don't all do that the final
scene of the film reveals that the evers
family is still dealing with leota
the fortune teller ghost as well as the
barbershop quartet who exists as singing
statues in the graveyard
what the film doesn't explain is why
these ghosts stuck around
did they choose to because being spooky
is fun did they get stuck in the objects
they possess
we don't know but if they're stuck and
need to be let out that's very
unfair the human journey of the haunted
mansion is that of the evers family as
they try to navigate their personal
issues
namely jim's workaholic tendencies and
his son michael's paralyzing fear of
spiders
while also trying to help a cursed group
of people find their way to the light
in the end after plenty of shenanigans
they succeed
breaking the curse of gracie manor by
revealing the truth about what happened
to elizabeth
and allowing her to be with edward again
while also defeating the evil ramsley
for their trouble they are awarded the
deed to gracie manor in the form of a
big
ribbon-tied scroll handed to them by
edward before he departs for the
afterlife
it's a nice little moment in some ways
after all it's the ultimate victory for
a pair of realtors to nab a mansion that
they can do whatever they want with
but there's a reason a lot of haunted
house movies don't touch on this issue
it forces us to ask who has owned the
mansion since edward died
has the local government simply
forgotten about it or has edward forged
paperwork to make himself look like his
own great grandson so he can keep the
property taxes current
and for that matter who installed things
like the phone line
it all unravels if you think about it
from a homeowner's perspective
most of the fantasy stuff in the haunted
mansion as the title suggests
revolves around ghosts a decades-old
curse fell on the house after a tragedy
the ghosts can't leave while the curse
is in place hauntings are not only
supernatural happenings at gracie manor
though
there's also a very prominent element of
magic in certain plot points
madame leota the fortune teller trapped
in a crystal ball
is apparently still very good at
prophecy and ramsley the evil butler
reveals that he has certain magical
tricks of his sleeves
including an ability to magically lock
jim out of the house
then at the end ramsley tries to summon
some evil ghosts to fight edward
only to be defeated when a full-blown
dragon made of fire jumps out of the
fireplace
and drags him down to hell even setting
aside the idea that the film seems to be
explicitly evoking hell as a place of
fire and punishment
where did the dragon come from was he
hanging out the whole time
who summoned him were forces in another
realm just watching all of this drama
unfold
waiting for their moment clearly there
are bigger things happening in this
movie's haunted world than what we're
seeing on screen
please don't drop me i'm fragile i'm
very fragile
don't talk to me about being fragile i'm
the one that's feeling fragile right now
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one